what's that believe nation I want to
give you a huge huge huge huge thank you
over the Easter weekend I'm in a video
asking you to support a friend of mine
friend of the chain the friend of belief
nation named Mark who I encourage to get
back on to making one of his youtube
series that he had walked away from
around two years ago please go to the
video support him leave a comment drop
some believe love on this fine human
being now in my head I was hoping to get
a hundred comments on that video usually
mark gets a couple comments on a video
he tries to reply to them but I thought
listen if we could send a hundred
comments over the mark hopeful that
gives him a little extra motivation and
boost to keep this series going you guys
blew me away
we had over 1,100 comments at least as
of the time of this video being filmed
and I got in to respond to the comments
mark has been drowning in the comments
as well not used to the belief nation
love and overwhelm and I just wanted to
one give you guys a quick thank you and
then to also show marks appreciation he
recorded a video showing his thanks and
how he's feeling that I thought you guys
deserve to see to I'm I'm speechless
guys I don't know what to say
and for anyone who knows me they know
that that's a rare thing but holy smokes
the outpouring of love and of comments
and everything from believe nation my
goodness Evan and the leave nation
brought it this weekend you guys
overwhelmed me with
with support you know for me Easter is
my favorite weekend it's my favorite
time of year it's a time of reflection
it's a time of spending time with family
it's a time where I can take stock of
the things that I feel blessed for
having in my life and all week from from
whenever Evans email his his email at
his video went out just comment after
comment after comment on the video which
guy's like ladies gentlemen it means it
means so much to me it was a it's
overwhelming and and humbling and
amazing
so I appreciate it I am trying to work
through the comments I want to read and
comment every single person but I'm
gonna be honest with you I'm used to
getting like 1 2 3 comments on a video
I'm not used to getting a thousand plus
and so I appreciate it I think each of
you so much for taking the time though
this is gonna happen that I guess I
guess that's gonna be a regular thing
Evan I was been sick for 2 years that I
got to bring that I got to bring it back
that I got a step up I got to make it
happen and so thank you thank you Evan
thank you for leave nation thank you all
and now I just got to figure out how to
make this happen and how to make it
better now this took up a huge chunk of
my weekend and week when this video was
posted live I was at the CN tower
tallest building at least in North
America freestanding structure one of
them in the world and we took Kayden we
took his cousin's and had a ton of fun
and I'm sitting there responding when
we're sending in a line I'm loading up
YouTube on my mobile and I'm responding
to you guys when the kids went to bed
I'm responding to you guys the next
morning I'm responding to you guys so
responded to a ton of comments from you
guys and maybe not the most productive
use or the best use of my time I fell
behind at a bunch of work mark and I are
working on a project together that I
haven't gotten back to him on at all
because this is how I've been spending
my time but it's also just I don't know
I get obsessed about these things and
something I love doing is is there a
tangible ROI
who knows probably not is it worth worth
the time doing if everybody probably not
compared to what I could be doing I just
love doing it I felt like everybody who
me supportive Marg deserve to get a
comment back and it was a lot of fun and
so yeah I might have pushed some other
higher priority projects aside to make
this happen but I'm but that's what I
like doing
no no regrets in doing that so thank you
guys so much for your support
means a lot to me you guys blew me away
you blew Marc away it was a fantastic
surprise and you know I encourage you to
continue to do it one of one of my
favorite things to do with supporting
people who are on their way up
supporting people who may not believe in
themselves every now and then just
having somebody give you a little bit of
push a little bit of confidence a little
bit of belief when they're looking in
the mirror telling themselves you can't
do something telling themselves that
they're not valuable enough telling
themselves that they can't contribute
enough just having one person sometimes
makes all the difference if you see a
small YouTube creator who's channeling
you really like leave a comment just
support them if you see a friend trying
to go off and do something and they've
been beaten down or they failed or they
lost just just cheer them up support
them and tell them that you believe in
them tell them to keep going sometimes
just that one comment that one pat on
the back that one I believe in you that
makes the entire difference between them
continuing on and chasing their dreams
and then quitting and going back to a
life in a job that they hate and to know
that like you could be that difference
that's what I strive to do on a daily
basis with my content every single day
we had a huge impact on mark this week
together I encourage all of you to
continue to do that for the people in
your life who you just want to show some
support to because we all need it every
now and then so thank you guys again
really appreciate it I believe in you I
hope we continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is much love
I'll see you soon guys raise your
standard
not one drop of myself work depends on
your acceptance of me
I don't ever give up I'd have to be dead
or absolutely incapacitated hey believe
nation if you want to see my all-time
favorite top ten roses success I have a
very special secret video for you these
are the individual clips that I have
personally learned the most from and
applied to my life and my business check
the link the description for details